[Musique]
bonjour bonjour à tous très heureuse de
vous retrouver sur Public Sénat c'est
l'heure d'avoir 20 ans l'occasion de
plonger dans ces sujets qui préoccupent
particulièrement la jeunesse mais qui
nous intéresse tous et cette semaine on
va parler d'un sujet universel c'est le
bien le plus précieux c'est le principal
fondement de la société ce n'est pas moi
qui le dit c'est Aristote et je veux
parler de l'amitié on va essayer de
comprendre la place de l'amitié dans la
vie des jeunes dans notre vie à tous
comment ce lien social nous construit et
construit notre société alors que notre
monde est révolutionné aujourd'hui par
les réseaux sociaux entre tchat like
followers les réseaux sociaux qui nous
permettent d'entrer en contact avec de
plus en plus de monde mais est-ce qu'on
peut parler pour autant d'amis sur ce
plateau des jeunes et des experts pour
échanger sur ce beau sujet j'ai le
plaisir d'accueillir Léonie garabito
bonjour vous avez 19 ans vous êtes
étudiante en licence à l'Université
Paris Créteil et voilà votre rapport
avec vos amis c'est que vous les voyez
quotidiennement votre groupe d'amis
serrés disons et vous utilisez beaucoup
les réseaux sociaux pour garder le
contact pour entretenir le réseau à côté
Anissa que nous avons le plaisir de
retrouver que nous avions déjà reçu dans
cette émission on avait parlé santé
mentale sur ce plateau alors je rappelle
vous avez 22 ans vous êtes militante
créatrice de contenu et vous êtes
fondatrice de l'association jungans safe
qui lutte contre les violences sur les
enfants et pour vous les amis c'est ce
que vous nous avez dit c'est votre
famille de coeur vous allez nous
expliquer comment également sur ce
plateau Roger suis bonjour vous êtes
professeur émérite à la faculté des
sciences humaines et sociales de
l'Université de parité vous êtes
également membre permanent du service
c'est un laboratoire de recherche en
sciences sociales du CNRS et de la
Sorbonne et enfin pour compléter ce
plateau j'ai le plaisir d'accueillir
Philippe Duverger bonjour vous êtes
pédopsychiatre chef du service de la
psychiatrie de l'enfant et de
l'adolescent au CHU d'Angers et vous
êtes l'auteur de plusieurs livres entre
autres de la petite voiture rouge au
fond de mon tiroir Anne Carrière 2014 et
de l'amitié à l'adolescence à la
découverte de soi chez First édition en
2022 et pour commencer cette émission on
va s'intéresser à une bande d'amis
d'enfance alors il se connaissent depuis
toujours ou presque ils entretiennent
comme vous Léonie leur amitié avec de
nombreux réseaux sociaux comment
fonctionne cette bande qu'est-ce qui
qu'est-ce que leur apporte ce lien
privilégié jonathan dupiez est allé les
rencontrer rencontrer cette bande de
copains d'abord regardez
Fontenay-sous-Bois en banlieue
parisienne il est 22h quant Aurélie
accueille ses ailes ses amis de toujours
au programme du vendredi match de
l'équipe de France autour de l'apéro une
rencontre que tous écoute d'une oreille
distraite dans l'euphorie des
retrouvailles
[Applaudissements]
Clément Lena Patrick et Aurélie se sont
rencontrés pour la plupart au collège
depuis ces soirées hebdomadaires sont
devenus à un rituel quasi indispensable
sans eux j'avancerai pas on se voit
toutes les semaines et pour moi ils sont
plus importants que ma famille limite je
les vois plus que ma femme ma propre
famille donc c'est c'est ma deuxième
famille 15 ans plus tard malgré des
choix de vie différents le groupe tient
bien renforcé par l'usage quotidien des
réseaux sociaux je pense que ça renforce
énormément notre amitié des vidéos sur
Instagram on va
les envoyer parce que ça va nous
rappeler des souvenirs sur snapchat on
va avoir des mémories donc on va en
recréer derrière
et sur WhatsApp ça va être plus pour se
tenir au courant ou se dire des bêtises
qui viennent de nous arriver on a un
délire par exemple avec Patrick ou à
chaque fois qu'il voit des des magasins
ou des épiceries où il y a Oscar dessus
il est obligé de le photographier de
nous l'envoyer voilà
ses amitiés profondes issus des jeunes
années sont une source d'inspiration
intarissable pour les écrivains chez
colombe Schneck notamment l'amitié
occupe une place centrale dans son œuvre
l'amitié est un lien gratuit il y a pas
de loi il y a pas d'obligation
législatives il y a pas d'obligation
contractuelles l'amitié c'est un lien
d'attention de générosité entièrement
gratuit s'il y a une célébration dans
mon séjour paradis c'est celui-là c'est
la célébration de l'amitié dans son
dernier ouvrage largement
autobiographique mensonge au Paradis
Colomb Schneck relate ses souvenirs de
vacances dans un chalet en Suisse c'est
dans cet endroit idyllique au pied des
montagnes qu'elle se lit d'amitié avec
Vava et Patou les enfants ont des
propriétaires du lieu mais leur lien se
distend et 30 ans plus tard au moment de
reprendre contact avec eux l'écrivaine
découvre les trajectoires contrariées de
ces deux amis d'enfance mais malgré un
lien qui semble s'être éthiolée les
fondements de cette amitié d'enfance
sont restés intactes quand je suis
revenu retrouver des amis d'enfance
j'avais pas vu depuis 30 ans
tous m'ont dit la même chose tu viens à
la maison quand tu veux tu viens dormir
à la maison tu t'installes il y a pas eu
une question voilà il y a pas une
question pourquoi tu as disparu pendant
30 ans dans son roman Colomb shnek
explore l'amitié dans toute sa
complexité avec ses bonheurs intensifs
et ses faux semblants en explorant le
passé des autres elle tente de mieux
comprendre le sien
[Musique]
pour votre famille parce que vous faites
la comparaison pense que je ressens des
choses qui qui se ressemblent mais qui
ne sont pas les mêmes par exemple de
l'amour tout simplement pour moi il y a
de l'amour dans l'amitié comme dans
l'amour il y a beaucoup d'amitié aussi
moi j'ai de l'amour pour mes amis je les
aime pour moi je pense que l'amitié
c'est la plus belle chose la plus belle
histoire qu'on peut vivre dans une vie
vous êtes d'accord Léonie vous le dites
vous aussi cette comparaison qu'on a vu
aussi dans dans le reportage vous dites
vos amitiés sont plus importantes
aujourd'hui que que vos relations
familiales pourquoi alors déjà c'est ma
mère qui me le dit beaucoup parce que je
déserte souvent la maison au passé du
temps avec mes amis elle s'en plaint oui
donc c'est un hôtel tout ça donc voilà
après c'est parce que ma mère me disait
la même chose
vu que j'habite chez eux j'ai pas là
j'ai moins ce besoin de faire l'effort
en fait de du coup de faire des choses
avec
plus important que ma famille je sais
pas parce que voilà j'ai deux petites
sœurs avec qui je m'entends hyper bien
et que je vois tout le temps
d'une part parce que j'habite avec elle
mais pas que mais après c'est vrai que
vous choisissez pas voilà c'est un peu
différent
mais voilà mais du coup mes amis oui
c'est des gens que enfin je les vois
beaucoup j'essaye au maximum d'ailleurs
parce que j'en ai plein qui sont à
l'étranger aussi donc c'est pas toujours
évident ça du coup on en parlera tout à
l'heure par rapport aux réseaux sociaux
mais oui du coup c'est des enfin
j'essaye au maximum et est-ce que vous
direz que ça a toujours été comme ça
pour vous est-ce qu'il y a un âge où et
bien les relations amicales ont pris le
dessus sur les relations familiales
quant à un moment vous pouvez signer ça
oui je pense que c'est à partir de
mi-collège quoi je dirais vers la
cinquième quatrième bah dès que
l'adolescence ça commence un petit peu
ouais vous sentiez moins mieux compris
par vos amis peut-être que par une
famille à cette époque
enfin je sais que bah du coup il y a des
gens pour qui c'est encore moins évident
mais il y a pas énormément de dialogue
par rapport à ça chez moi et du coup ça
fait que c'était hyper libérateur en
fait de
dans ma vie ou quand on s'affirme en
fait quand on devient vraiment qui on a
envie d'être bah ça va pas forcément
avec les choix de sa famille et les amis
on les choisir on choisit des gens qui
nous ressemblent et là on peut être
libre d'être vraiment qui on est des
mecs qui ont vu de faire les choix qu'on
souhaite quoi et on a soutenu vous
parler liberté Philippe Duverger dans
votre livre donc sur l'amitié
adolescente vous rappelez d'ailleurs ce
que dit Aristote sur le fait que
l'amitié authentique ne peut naître que
d'un libre choix c'est exactement ce que
l'on observe ici autrement dit
ça se distingue peut-être d'autres
relations comme les relations familiales
parce qu'il y a aucune obligation
non il y a aucune obligation il y a
aucun calcul il y a aucun enjeu de
pouvoir il y a aucun contrat
contrairement à d'autres types de
relations on est dans quelque chose qui
s'installe et qui et qui peut-être des
fois même sans explication va faire que
ça va s'installer dans le temps parce
que l'amitié ça s'inscrit dans le temps
c'est pas quelque chose de ponctuel pour
y revenir par rapport aux réseaux
sociaux ça s'inscrit dans le temps
parfois même on est surpris mais c'était
dit par l'écrivain n'a que on ne voit
pas ses amis pendant 20 ans et puis on
les revoit et on a l'impression que
voilà et donc c'est à dire qu'il y a
quelque chose qui se nous qui est
fondamental qui est très important qui
ne relève pas d'une obligation ou d'un
choix
imposé mais qui au contraire
renvoie sans doute ce que l'on est un
peu soi-même c'est pour ça que dans le
sous-titre du livre oui l'amitié à
l'adolescence
qui participe aussi à la construction de
soi justement c'était la question que
j'allais vous poser quel est pour vous
le rôle de l'amitié dans notre
construction psychique en quoi est-ce
que c'est important pour pour construire
une personne particulièrement à
l'adolescence je dirais qu'on a besoin
de l'amitié pour pour grandir on a
besoin des autres pour grandir et on a
besoin aussi des autres pour savoir qui
on est
moi je suis psychiatre et puis c'est
vrai que quand on est tout petit par
exemple prenant un nourrisson quand il
se regarde dans la glace il sait pas qui
c'est il sait pas ce que c'est voilà or
il y a quelqu'un qui est à côté de lui
sa mère son père qui va dire mes étoiles
ok donc on apprend qui est qui on est je
dirais grâce à la parole de l'autre on a
besoin de l'altérité pour se construire
pour se reconnaître exactement et on
voit d'ailleurs avec les enfants
sauvages ceux qui sont nés dans les
forêts comment finalement l'humanisation
passe par l'autre et c'est fantastique
c'est à dire que pour se construire on a
besoin des autres ça part de là dès la
petite enfance et à l'adolescence quand
on va quitter justement mais ses parents
la famille on va se séparer sans se
perdre bien évidemment il va falloir à
ce moment-là
combler le vide que les parents
n'occupent plus et on va combler ça avec
des amis des amis qui vont justement
nous aider à grandir à nous construire
et même à savoir qui on est on ne peut
pas grandir sans amis
Roger su est-ce que du coup la business
l'adolescence puis la vingtaine c'est un
peu la période qui qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui c'est le moment peut-être on
ressent le plus les amis comme peut-être
indispensable pour pour se construire
peut-être par rapport à d'autres
périodes de notre vie ou on sera
peut-être plus dans des cellules
familiales par exemple est-ce que
dans les âges de la vie bien sûr on
passe une relation qui est effectivement
qui est comme ça a été dit qu'il a été
choisi à faire des relations choisies
mais je crois que l'amitié s'encre
plutôt et plus elle s'en racine au fond
dans la jeunesse on dit souvent ami
d'enfance c'est souvent d'ailleurs
parallèle à mi d'enfance et pourquoi
c'est parce que enfant on n'a pas de
rôle enfant d'une certaine façon on est
soi-même et ce qui va caractériser
l'amitié c'est le fait que traversant
des rôles sociaux différents familiaux
professionnels associatif etc
des amis vont vous l'avez bien dit
d'ailleurs vont rester en forme de
miroir pour savoir où on en est et qui
on est mais ils vont être là en
permanence à vous suivre dans vos
différents
évolutions sincérité initiale peut-être
vraiment quelque chose de voilà très
premier vous savez enfin je sors en même
temps de de la tétralogie de faire en
thé vous savez sur la Microvision
parce que c'est vraiment c'est vraiment
exemplaire de l'amitié des oppositions
et et et de deux personnes qui ne se
ressemblent pas qui vont avoir des
trajectoires très différentes mais qui
vont se situer toujours l'une par
rapport à l'autre comme les espèces de
dément parce que nous nous savons qui
nous sommes nous nous sommes connus
vraiment avant même au fond d'être
une personnalité avant même d'échanger à
l'extérieur alors après il y a
effectivement la sortie de la famille et
passer d'une relation disons un peu
verticale vers des relations de plus en
plus horizontales qui permettent à soi
de s'exprimer peut-être plus pleinement
et de pas être simplement le fils ou la
fille de voilà vous parlez de la de
l'ami prodigieuse des affaires hantées
et des suites l'amitié on l'a vu avec
l'écrivaine que l'on schnak c'est une
source d'inspiration c'est une source
presque de de fascination aujourd'hui
qu'est-ce que ça dit du rôle de l'amitié
dans notre société dans notre
construction sociale aujourd'hui
ça dit ça dit deux choses d'abord si on
remonte un peu dans l'histoire d'abord
Montaigne peut-être
définition moi je pense un dépassable de
l'amitié parce que c'était lui parce que
c'était moi et au fond il y a quelque
chose d'un contrôlable qu'on ne sait pas
pourquoi au fond c'est parce qu'on peut
dire c'est du mimétisme mais on peut
dire c'est de la catharsis et au
contraire c'est de l'opposition non on
sait pas ça peut être les deux
d'ailleurs on a des amis qui vous
ressemblent puis des amis qui vous
ressemblent pas du tout
je crois
l'amitié
beaucoup plus
indispensable aujourd'hui ou les
supports institutionnels quand même
s'effrites c'est-à-dire que l'idée que
la vie est tracée que notre personnalité
va être façonnée par l'entrée dans la
vie active on va trouver un travail
qu'on va se marier etc toutes ces
institutions qui sont de plus en plus
évanescente vous renvoie à vous-même et
vous renvoie effectivement à une forme
d'auto-construction c'est le fameux
nietzsche1 devient ce que tu es et là il
faut quand même dire parce que votre
ce dont nous parlons c'est d'amitié en
général mais nous ne sommes pas égaux
d'une certaine façon de devant l'amitié
aussi comme il y a une pluralité de
jeunesse vous voyez et développer quand
même une amitié je pense que vous en
parlerez développer une amitié ça
suppose quand même une certaine
confiance en soi c'est à la fois une
construction de soi mais en même temps
il faut quand même se dire je suis
capable capable de je suis capable
d'être aimé et je suis capable d'être
aimé un peu à la à la façon du
sociologue Marcel Moss dans le dans le
don et le contredo
vous voyez au chat de la tête à Nice
compliqué de revenir sur pourquoi j'ai
fâché absolument d'accord sur sur tout
et sur le fait que c'est c'est essentiel
enfin moi j'en pense à mes amis je me
dis mais en fait écoutez je me disais
mes anneaux d'envie de pleurer tellement
j'aime mes amis c'est
indispensable et dans la construction
enfin comment on se regarde on dit mais
qui suis-je moi je me compare enfin à
mes amis je regarde où est-ce qu'on en
est comment on a évolué et on voit à
quel point bah quand on disait c'est les
amis d'enfance ça nous rappelle aussi
qui on est on regarde on se dit bah en
fait on a pris des trajectoires
complètement différents et bah peut-être
qu'il y a besoin de se séparer et c'est
justement ça qui nous renvoie à
nous-mêmes et se dire ok bah je suis
devenu telle personne que je n'étais pas
il y a il y a 15 ans donc c'est à la
base de tout et Léonie je vous fais
peut-être rebondir aussi sur ce que vous
disiez Roger dessus et sur aussi
peut-être bah peut-être dans notre monde
aujourd'hui tel qu'il est l'amitié c'est
c'est très important pour pour centrer
pour ceux pour se comprendre et pour se
construire
c'est quand même genre indispensable à
ma vie mais voilà j'ai moins ce truc les
amis de longue date je suis jeune donc
ce sera que ça peut être des enfants
les les amis de les amis de lycée les
amis d'université c'est des amis enfin
ça peut être des amis pour la vie qu'il
faut avoir beaucoup d'amis et que celui
qui a beaucoup d'amis n'a pas d'amis les
amis se comptent sur les doigts d'une
main oui on a des potes on a des bandes
de potes on a des camarades on a des
copains des copines là on parle vraiment
des amis et c'est normal que des
connaissances d'enfance peuvent se
perdre seulement 10 ans 20 ans 30 ans
après il en reste une deux amitiés et
c'est là qu'on voit des des petits bouts
de vérité de nous-mêmes c'est vraiment
finalement des boussoles qui nous aident
à grandir moi je trouve que l'amitié
c'est une boussole qui nous aide à
grandir à savoir qui on est ce que je
disais ça nous repart par rapport à
comment on a évolué est-ce que vous
est-ce qu'on en est quoi exactement une
seule il y a un mot oui en réfléchissant
je le disais mais si je devais essayer
de qualifier
l'amitié d'un mot c'est n'importe quoi
en fait
je me suis dit il y a quand même le mot
inconditionnalité voyez c'est à dire que
il y a quelque chose qui inconditionnel
dans l'amitié quand l'amitié est
vraiment très forte elle est à la fois
permanente dans le temps et elle est à
la fois aussi
inconditionnelle et je partage le fait
que effectivement on en parlera
peut-être il y a des études qui montrent
que soit disant on aurait moins d'amis
mais on va en parler
on va ouvrir un petit peu d'ailleurs ce
chapitre on l'a bien compris l'amitié
était essentielle pour nous construire
c'est un des fondements de notre société
d'où la douleur aussi que représente la
solitude or les jeunes sont de plus en
plus touchés par la solitude c'est le
constat fait par SOS Amitié et nous
sommes avec Gilles scène de Seigne
présidente de SOS Amitié France en visio
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous bonjour
Alors vous recevez beaucoup d'appels de
de jeunes
plus que d'adultes encore aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pouvez un petit peu nous
donner bien un petit peu le panorama de
la situation aujourd'hui notamment sur
les jeunes
alors bonjour à tous oui alors avant de
parler de faire un focus sur les sur les
jeunes juste deux mots sur SOS Amitié
puisque c'est une association d'écoute
de la souffrance psychique en général
qui existe depuis 63 ans nous décrochons
un peu près 650 000 appels par an sur 3
millions qui arrivent sur notre
plateforme nationale donc c'est assez
conséquent
l'autre comment les appels sont anonymes
confidentiels et inconditionnel vous
avez repris ce terme tout à l'heure
donc la partie anonyme est importante
parce que sur les les éléments chiffrés
que je vais vous donner pour les jeunes
derrière
c'est c'est ce qu'on entend et ce qu'on
comprend des échanges qu'on a avec les
personnes qui nous appellent c'est
absolument pas une statistique
scientifique pour autant ça donne des
tendances assez intéressantes alors sur
les 650 000 appels que nous décrochons
chaque année ça représente environ 5%
donc ça peut paraître peu ça représente
quand même à peu près 30 000 appels de
jeunes ce qu'on peut
constater dès à présent en 2022 c'est
que par rapport à l'avant covid nous
avons une augmentation du contact des
jeunes alors sur des aspects pour nous
ont été
sont une alerte ont été une alerte et
reste une alerte c'est qu'il nous
recontacte par téléphone et une forte
progression entre l'année 2020 et 2021
puisque nous avons noté à peu près 20%
d'appels de jeunes donc en dessous de 24
ans en plus au téléphone que par rapport
à l'année 2020 alors qu'est-ce que ça
montre exactement sur le sur le covid ça
a montré que la crise covid a joué un
rôle important dans la situation
actuelle qui a eu la crise sanitaire un
peu derrière nous qu'aujourd'hui il y a
quand même une traîne c'est ça qu'on
observe dans les périodes de confinement
les jeunes comme tout le monde ont été
ont été un petit peu séparés des liens
réels et donc ils ont un petit peu de
mal aujourd'hui à recréer ces liens ou à
les faire perdurer et du coup c'est nous
pensons c'est absolument
pas comment traduit scientifiquement
parlant ça les les experts en soins nous
le diront après mais nous pensons que
les jeunes ont besoin de cette réalité
humaine au travers d'une conversation au
travers de déposer des angoisses
éventuellement qui peuvent avoir par
rapport à tel ou tel thème donc en tout
cas en 2022 ça n'a pas diminué d'accord
et quand les jeunes vous appellent vous
avez le sentiment que ce sont des jeunes
qui sont objectivement plus seuls ou
qu'il ressent de la solitude ce que pas
forcément dire qu'ils sont
pas avec des gens autour d'eux mais il y
a un sentiment quand même de solitude de
quoi on parle exactement quand on parle
de solitude alors voilà j'allais en
venir quels sont les motifs d'appel des
jeunes alors la majeure partie des
jeunes en dessous de 24 ans a toujours
sont celles ils ont des problèmes de
relation parents-enfants globalement ça
c'est majoritaire ils nous font part de
leur idée suicidaire très liés bien sûr
à l'adolescence donc ça représente
environ 20% des appels de ces jeunes
font état d'idées suicidaires je n'ai
pas forcément accompagné de conduite
suicidaire c'est à dire qu'on lui
considère anorexie
drogue etc
donc au niveau du covid ce qui a été un
petit peu plus important en termes de
motif d'appel c'était ce qui était lié à
la maltraitance
ça a été confirmé un peu en 2022 et là
effectivement nous avons eu beaucoup
plus d'appels qui faisaient état d'un
sentiment de solitude il y avait un fort
sentiment de solitude notamment chez les
étudiants qui étaient coupés à la fois
de leur cours au niveau de la fac mais
également souvent de leur famille et
donc ils étaient ils étaient seuls dans
leur petit studio souvent donc
évidemment
en écho des problèmes de scolarité et
d'études qui ont été plus importants en
2021 et qui continue un petit peu en
queue de comète sur 2022
ce qui est important c'est
qu'aujourd'hui en 2012
regarde beaucoup les
indicateurs au jour d'aujourd'hui ça
nous donne à penser que les jeunes
s'inquiètent aussi bien sûr pour leur
avenir qu'est-ce que je vais devenir
donc qu'est-ce que je vais devenir aussi
dans le monde de demain par rapport aux
climat par rapport à des conflits et ça
il nous il nous le donne à penser aussi
et bien aujourd'hui merci beaucoup
Ghislaine de saigne pour ce panorama et
pour nous avoir présenté voilà et bien
SOS Amitié et cette initiative qui vient
en aide à de nombreuses personnes et à
de nombreux jeunes Philippe Duverger on
a parlé de cette augmentation de la
solitude chez les adolescents de cette
augmentation des inquiétudes aussi
est-ce que c'est quelque chose que vous
avez vous observez en consultation liées
au covid ou non alors il y a deux choses
d'abord je pense que la solitude c'est
un passage obligé de l'adolescence un
moment donné on se pose des questions
sur ces relations aux autres et quand
tout va bien bien évidemment on a sa
bande de potes on a sa bande de voilà où
on va se construire très bien mais pour
certains ça va être difficile d'établir
des liens on n'est pas tous égaux
forcément en effet et cette solitude
fait partie je dirais d'une étape à
franchir pour chaque cadeau après par
rapport à la question du Chris codes de
la crise covid c'est vrai que finalement
beaucoup d'ados vulnérables on souffert
de cet étrange solitude de ces liens
rompus au niveau de la de l'Incarnation
c'est à dire qu'on pouvait avoir des
relations par visio mais ça ne change
face à ça ça ne remplace en rien la
relation amitié elle doit être incarnée
c'est une question de corps aussi on
doit se toucher on doit se on doit aussi
aussi absolument et ça ça a beaucoup
manqué et le ressort s'est cassé pour
beaucoup certains aujourd'hui n'ont plus
la possibilité ou
bon pour dire l'envie de retourner au
lycée ou au collège il y a ouais tout à
fait il y a beaucoup d'addictions aux
écrans et si la crise sanitaire médicale
est terminée le virus ne circule plus au
niveau psychologique c'est pas le cas du
tout on est en pleine crise et encore
une longue traîne on n'a jamais vu
autant d'urgence psychologique avec des
jeunes en effet qui sont en souffrance
et qui disent au final ouais mais j'ai
des hautes autour de moi mais j'ai
l'impression d'être un isolé rassemblée
nicotin des isolés rassemblés
c'est-à-dire qu'on est tous ensemble
mais en ce sens parfois jamais plus seul
que quand on est au milieu des autres ça
devient sur la solitude
est-ce que vous l'avez vous ressenti ou
ressenti à travers ce que vous voilà sur
les sur les réseaux sociaux vous avez
aussi beaucoup de jeunes qui doivent qui
témoignent auprès de leur de leur état
de santé mentale est-ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous avez alors moi
c'est quelque chose que j'ai ressenti
mais au niveau des jeunes vu que j'ai la
possibilité de rapporter la parole de
certaines personnes c'est vrai que moi
il y a beaucoup de jeunes qui m'ont
écrit parce que j'ai fait beaucoup de
vidéos voilà je parlais de de
[Musique]
par exemple des traumatismes d'enfance
etc qui se sont retrouvés face en fait à
ces problématiques là seul chez eux avec
les parents ou non on étudiants dans son
logement et là bah ils se sont retrouvés
démunis et deux ans trois ans après on a
l'impression que le covid date d'hier et
que bah on n'a pas avancé absolument
Léonie vous avez ressenti vous de la
solitude pas forcément liée au covid
plutôt parce que vous vous racontiez
parfois dans certaines universités ou
vous êtes arrivés vous avez un peu
débarqué comment ça s'est passé oui bah
bien sûr bah du coup oui plutôt à
l'université que le covid parce que moi
le covid à l'inverse enfin j'ai eu plein
de temps pour moi en fait et j'ai adoré
bien vécu voilà je suis pas sorti une
seule fois de tout le confinement et
c'est pas grave et il y en a qui ont
vécu leurs meilleurs amis
après voilà j'avais de la chance du coup
parce que j'avais une situation à ce
moment-là familiale qui était bien il y
a de la place donc voilà mais ouais par
exemple à l'université ça a été
compliqué parce que donc du coup j'étais
à l'École alsacienne et ensuite j'ai la
Catho Paris donc c'est dans la même rue
et du coup déjà j'étais pas hyper
contente moi j'avais envie de bouger un
petit peu etc c'est pas ce qui s'est
fait et donc peut-être que j'abordais
pas la chose de façon hyper positive de
base mais en fait j'ai eu beaucoup de
mal à aller vers les gens parce que bah
vu que l'école où j'étais avant j'y
étais de la sixième à la terminale en
fait moi j'avais l'habitude d'être avec
les mêmes personnes donc j'allais plus
de moi-même en fait faire des nouvelles
personnes complètement parce que là je
connaissais personne connaissance et bah
j'ai tissé des liens rapidement avec
quelques personnes mais je les voyais
pas du tout en dehors etc et du coup je
pense que ça a joué sur le fait que bah
j'ai pas continué dans cette école là et
là pour le coup donc là où je me suis
réorienté en fait il y a plein de choses
qui avaient été mises en place enfin les
gens créent des groupes WhatsApp avant
même la rentrée ce qui fait que j'ai pu
rencontrer des gens avant même la
rentrée et il se trouve que
maintenant ils sont qu'il y a de ces
personnes là qui ont été dans mon groupe
après et donc de qui maintenant je suis
très etc mais oui non bah c'était mieux
organisé après c'est des gens qui ont un
an de plus que moi et bah c'est quelque
chose que j'ai remarqué c'est qu'en fait
bah ils sont très sur les réseaux
sociaux du coup par rapport alors qu'il
y a que un an d'écart donc c'est pas
c'est une différence de génération mais
oui du coup ça a changé et je suis très
bien là où je suis on va parler des
réseaux dans un instant mais
ce phénomène dont on parle aux
États-Unis celui de la récession de
l'amitié cette crise de solitude qui qui
existe aux États-Unis qui a été
amplifiée par l'épidémie de covid et
dont parle certains chercheurs vous vous
estimez que en tout cas ce n'est pas ce
que vous observez en France aujourd'hui
il faut nuancer d'abord je pense qu'il
faut distinguer l'isolement et la
solitude
l'isolement c'est un fait objectif et la
solitude c'est quand même aussi un vécu
subjectif donc on vient de le dire
d'ailleurs vous avez dit on peut être
seul au milieu d'une foule donc voilà
donc je pense qu'il faut isoler ça les
études américaines et anglaises c'est
assez curieuse d'ailleurs elle converge
là-dessus pour dire les gens au moins
d'amis mais il y a une vraie confusion
autour de ce qu'est l'amitié parce que
de quoi de quoi parle-t-on est-ce qu'on
parle des contacts sociaux est-ce qu'on
parle des connaissances et ce qu'on
parle de toutes les relations que l'on a
où est-ce qu'on parle de l'amitié
en réalité il y a cette confusion et
cette confusion peut s'installer y
compris dans l'esprit des jeunes se
disant après tout les réseaux j'ai plein
d'ailleurs on dit les amis on dit plein
d'amis ce qui est quand même assez
curieux parce que voilà
ce réseau social de dinosaures
et c'est comme si on voulait que au fond
tout le monde soit des amis bah non la
vraie vie c'est pas possible d'ailleurs
c'est pas souhaitable et effectivement
on se construit seulement à travers un
certain nombre de personnes donc il y a
parfois un vécu qui est un peu difficile
parce que il y a ce challenge qui est
d'avoir beaucoup d'amis de Michel
beaucoup d'amis etc et donc je alors les
sociologues distinguent voilà
excusez-moi de parler des sociologues
distingue bien fort et bien faible vous
voyez et
partage à moitié cette distinction parce
que c'est comme si on disait que tous
les liens faibles connaissances se
substituer au lien fort alors je ne
crois pas ça je crois qu'on peut avoir
des liens faibles et des liens forts
alors on va s'intéresser
juste à la place des réseaux sociaux
dans les relations d'amitié qu'est-ce
que ça veut dire être ami aujourd'hui à
l'air d'Instagram on va s'intéresser à
ce phénomène qui est plus marqué chez
les jeunes que parmi les autres
générations celui qui consiste à avoir
des amis virtuels plutôt que physique et
pour en parler j'accueille Mathias Arès
[Musique]
bonjour Mathias bonjour et ce phénomène
dont je parlais à l'instant il a un nom
on parle de frending en bon français
tome le friending c'est l'acte d'initier
et d'entretenir une relation amicale via
les réseaux sociaux donc moins engageant
dans l'implication véritable qu'une
vraie relation cela permet aussi de
dépasser ses peurs de faire le premier
pas c'est en tout cas ce qu'a théoriser
le sociologue italien Antonio cassili
qui qualifie tout de même le friending
de lien social fait le sociologue
compare ce phénomène à toilettage
réciproque comme le faisait nos ancêtres
les primates en ce cherchant des puces
l'occasion de s'entraider et changer des
commentaires utiles moins de risques de
conflits aussi une sorte de
stabilisateur social si on veut alors
comme l'explique cassili ce lien d'un
nouveau type ne remplace pas les autres
mais les enrichis d'une autre
fonctionnalité la capacité de combler
les espaces vides existants entre les
différents groupes sociaux et est-ce que
ça marche du coup le friending Mathias
est plus jeune là où 35% des Français
sont d'accord avec le fait qu'il est
plus facile de créer des amitiés en
ligne plutôt que dans le monde physique
chez les adolescents et bien cette part
monte à 46% autre données selon l'étude
find your tribe publié en 2020 20% de ce
qu'on appelle les Millenials préfèrent
avoir des amis virtuels que physique
contre 13% de la population générale et
l'une des illustrations de ce phénomène
dans vos mots parler bien c'est snapchat
ce réseau qui a connaît un très grand
succès aujourd'hui c'est ça c'est le
réseau plébiscité par les jeunes le
petit fantôme alors snap qu'est-ce que
c'est bien c'est un réseau social de
messagerie visuelle ou les photos et les
vidéos sont éphémères alors il y a des
groupes mais il y a surtout des
conversations privées alors selon les
derniers chiffres publiés en 2022 94%
des 15 24 ans l'utilise en France et sur
ce réseau donc peut-être plus
qu'ailleurs particulièrement les
utilisateurs ont tendance aussi à
ajouter des gens qui ne connaissent pas
leur par ailleurs le réseau social a
aussi décidé de quantifier l'amitié
d'âme et comment on fait ça je suis bien
curieuse comment est-ce qu'on quantifie
l'amitié c'est très subjectif mais en
comptant les échanges de snap ces photos
éphémères alors on s'envoie mutuellement
un snap avec un ami et vous verrez un
smiley apparaître vous répétez
l'opération sous 24 heures et ça passera
à une flamme alors là c'est la machine
du snap trick qui est lancé donc c'est
le concept de quantifier les échanges
alors tant que les échanges persistent à
minima une fois toutes les 24 heures le
nombre à côté de la flamme grandit les
records du monde sont sans surprise
détenus par des Américaines Anna et
Lauren Lucky qui ont donc échangé
pendant plus de je l'ai noté 274 jours
consécutifs soit 8 ans alors certains
ils voient une manière de se donner 1794
74 pardon certains ils voient une
manière de se challenger entre amis pour
ne pas perdre ce statut qui les lit
d'autres un simple artifices pour pour
qui est plutôt proche de l'obligation
mais au final tu as est-ce qu'on peut
quantifier l'amitié ça c'est une vaste
question un merci beaucoup Mathias pour
toutes ces explications pour cette
présentation de snapchat voilà l'amitié
sous algorithme vous êtes présents
toutes les deux sur snapchat un peu
moins c'était vraiment quand j'avais 14
15 16 ans moi maintenant moi maintenant
pourquoi parce que pour moi c'est juste
un réseau social qui a perdu peut-être
de son intérêt je suis pas très photo
instantanée enfin je suis plus Instagram
photographie vidéo plutôt que snap
envoyer peut-être parfois pour raconter
un peu sa vie c'est plutôt pratique mais
sinon j'ai 10 personnes sur snap quoi
d'accord et et Léonie vous l'utilisez
vous avec qui comment bah du coup je
l'utilise plus mais aussi pour les amis
pro enfin je vais plutôt l'utiliser pour
le côté messagerie et voilà pour
raconter des trucs comme ça mais je vais
pas mettre des stories comme je le fais
sur Instagram j'ai pas du tout ce
réflexe là avec snapchat après il y a
plein de petit interviews assez rapides
et du coup bah c'est bien fait quand
même pour y passer du temps mais non
c'est plus pour la messagerie en fait
que je vais utiliser vous savez que ça
reste quand même l'un des réseaux
sociaux les plébiscités par les jeunes
je crois que c'est le aujourd'hui c'est
le premier vous avez snapchat puis
Instagram puis TikTok bon après j'ai
l'impression que c'est plus vers chez
les plus jeunes d'accord moi je vois que
en tout cas dans mes fréquentations et
dans mes amis c'est quoi c'est 15 15 20
plutôt dans ce donc là je pense surtout
au lycée
on va on va continuer à parler des
pratiques numériques des des jeunes nous
sommes en visio avec la sociologue
claire Belley bonjour vous êtes
spécialisés sur la jeunesse c'est
pratique numérique vous enseignez à
l'Université de Genève voilà on a eu
tous ces témoignages sur l'amitié sur
l'usage des réseaux sociaux
qu'est-ce qui caractérise pour vous
aujourd'hui les réseaux sociaux les plus
populaires chez les jeunes moi je voyais
moi-même que Tik Tok était en grande
progression Instagram aussi en tout cas
c'est pas du tout les mêmes réseaux que
ceux qui utilisent l'ensemble des
Français YouTube WhatsApp Facebook par
exemple
non alors c'est à dire qu'évidemment les
adolescents ont toujours le souci de se
distinguer des adultes et puis de gérer
aussi leur lien d'amitié et toute leur
petit écosystèmes relationnel de manière
un peu distincte et de surtout pas aller
sur les plateformes ou sont les adultes
donc une fois que les adultes sont
arrivés ont migré sur une plateforme ont
été les jeunes
d'ailleurs voilà c'est assez logique
qu'on les comprend donc voilà chaque
joueur va organiser un peu sa vie comme
ça dans son petit écosystème numérique
un organisant en fait en utilisant
chaque plateforme chaque application en
fonction de ses besoins et en fonction
des liens
et du coup de de comment les
utilise-t-il aujourd'hui est-ce qu'ils
sont importants par rapport au sujet
dont on parle sur la question de
l'amitié soit pour se faire des amis des
amis virtuels qui peuvent venir des amis
réels soit pour entretenir les relations
oui alors en fait c'est surtout
entretenir les relations si vous voulez
on le fait dans plusieurs espaces on le
fait dans des espaces présentiels à
l'école dans le bus si on va faire du
shopping au foot dans les vestiaires et
en fait toutes ces amitiés là vont être
entretenues dans ce prolonger finalement
sur les réseaux sociaux on va entretenir
le lien envoyer des signes d'infection
faire des clins d'oeil envoyer des
photos raconter sa vie raconter son
problème mais on va choisir en fait si
on fait un audio sur WhatsApp ou si on
poste une story sur sur snap ou si on
envoie un message sur TikTok à chaque
fois on va paramétrer en fait en
fonction un petit peu de ce qu'on veut
dire à qui dans quel contexte etc le
sociologue Antonio cassili que citait
tout à l'heure Mathias s'estime qu'il y
a une vraie différence entre l'amitié
classique un lien privé un peu
inconditionnel dont on parlait tout à
l'heure et puis ce qui s'affiche sur les
réseaux comme relation en public avec
presque une forme de mise en scène de
l'amitié par exemple est-ce que vous
aussi vous faites cette différence
comment est-ce que vous situez l'un par
rapport à l'autre ce le friending dont
on parlait par rapport à l'amitié
ce qui est spécifique peut-être à
l'adolescence quoique ça peut durer chez
certaines personnes c'est effectivement
le fait que si vous voulez votre capital
social est vraiment gage de prestige ok
quelqu'un de populaire si quelqu'un qui
va avoir beaucoup d'amis mais pas que si
quelqu'un qui va aussi avoir des amis
proches des meilleurs amis qui va voir
des premières relations amoureuses donc
à l'adolescence le lien social c'est
vraiment ce qui va vous donner du
prestige vous avez pas encore la grosse
voiture vous avez pas encore le métier
c'est ça qui va vous donner vous êtes
populaire donc en fait évidemment voilà
on veut montrer qu'on l'a en fait parce
que c'est comme ça qu'on devient
populaire et qu'on entretient aussi sa
popularité donc il y a un peu
effectivement cette idée que il faut
montrer que on a des amis mais aussi
pour leur prouver qu'ils sont nos amis
pour se prouver à soi-même qu'on a des
amis puis faire exister le lien sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est une manière de les
faire exister tout court ah oui c'est
intéressant parce que finalement c'est
un peu le prolongement de ce qu'on a pu
tous vivre peut-être dans les cours
d'école dans une cette petite sphère de
l'école où effectivement être popul
c'était très très important et on en
trouve le prolongement sur les réseaux
sociaux exactement c'est une scène en
fait c'est comme voilà le couple qui va
se tenir par la main pour montrer qu'il
est en couple ben on va le faire sur
Facebook on va pas le faire sur qu'on a
plus faire sur facebook plutôt sur
snapchat
Oui c'est la même logique est-ce que du
coup vous diriez que les codes des
réseaux sociaux
ils sont conformes à ceux de l'amitié
ils sont contraires à ceux de l'amitié
alors il y a cette notion de
prolongement comme je disais mais en
même temps clair que les réseaux sociaux
ils ont aussi leurs règles propres ce
qui se passe ce qui se fait pas il y a
beaucoup de choses qui vont se négocier
aussi sur les réseaux sociaux vous savez
sur snapchat par exemple les tribunaux
snapchat on va régler les problèmes sur
snap et puis on va convier le collectif
pour venir régler ça
à plusieurs donc en fait c'est pas tout
c'est pas les mêmes espaces c'est des
espaces qui sont
corrélés articulés mais c'est pas les
mêmes et c'est pas les mêmes règles donc
ça c'est c'est important de le signaler
bien merci merci beaucoup claire ballet
nous avons raconté tout cela je précise
que vous êtes donc soit cela et
spécialisé sur la jeunesse et les
pratiques numériques et que vous
enseignez à l'Université de Genève merci
beaucoup
Philippe Duverger faut qu'elle regarde
portez-vous sur les réseaux sociaux et
leur impact sur les relations sociales à
l'adolescence je vais être radicale les
amitiés virtuels n'existent pas vous
pensez que je le dis comme ça parce que
je pense qu'il faut vraiment redéfinir
ce qu'est l'amitié
les réseaux sociaux favorisent la
communication ça c'est vraiment
fondamental c'est parfait on a vu
pendant le covid c'est génial ça permet
de partager plein de choses mais avec
une illusion avec une illusion et qui
d'un point de vue psychologique ne
relève pas de l'amitié dans ce que moi
ce que j'en ai dans le cas défini c'est
vrai qu'aujourd'hui on a l'impression
que pour exister faut être vu alors
c'est pas ça du tout l'existence et je
pense que l'amitié elle doit être
incarnée là on est dans l'instantanéité
tout de suite maintenant on montre
l'amitié ça s'installe dans le temps
c'est quelque chose qui va durer des
années qui va qui va prendre du temps on
est vraiment antinomique pour moi ça
veut pas dire que ça peut être
complémentaire ça peut être très très
bien oui ça peut être complémentaire
quand c'est entretien les relations mais
vous dites ça peut être un outil au
service de mais on trompe
et je l'ai dit tout à l'heure quand on a
plein d'amis on n'a pas d'amis c'est pas
des ce sont pas pour moi des amis ce
sont des connaissances des liens forts
mais mais j'allais dire mais ce ne sont
pas pour moi en tous les cas ce que
j'appelle des amis on est dans dans une
illusion à mon avis et qui d'ailleurs je
le vois avec ceux qui vont mal
quand justement il y a plus de followers
quand il y a plus tout d'un coup ça et
que du jour au lendemain on se retrouve
et bien exclu par exemple d'un groupe
c'est l'effondrement c'est une
catastrophe et on voit bien la facticité
des relations à ce moment-là et c'est la
tentative de suicide qui arrive c'est là
que le
pédophilement c'est la je vais pas vous
enfin voilà mais mais on voit bien qu'à
ce moment-là et ce lien rompu montrer
que c'était pas de l'amitié c'est autre
chose et qui est important autre chose
absolument alors qu'est-ce que c'est
Roger qu'est-ce que c'est c'est
qu'est-ce qui représente aujourd'hui
dans nos relations sociales pour vous
c'est ces réseaux sociaux qui peuvent
avoir qui sont un peu ambivalents voilà
qui peuvent avoir cette dimension un peu
privée un peu public très très
instantané aujourd'hui dans dans notre
dans notre monde
les réseaux sociaux c'est c'est des
instruments et donc oui ce sont des
outils mais ces outils qui ont la
caractéristique d'effacées un peu les
frontières entre le réel et le virtuel
c'est un grès peut-être un peu de mon
voisin pour ça parce que je pense que on
est dans une société alors moi j'ai
tendance à raisonner comme vous mais
quand je vois les jeunes
le réel et le virtuel se confondent
franchement et donc il peut y avoir plus
de réel dans du virtuel parfois que etc
je vais vous prendre un exemple
on peut avoir des voisins de paliers
franchement bon on n'a pas trop envie de
parler avec eux voilà mais à l'autre
bout du monde il y a quelqu'un qui a la
même hobby la même pratique ou je sais
pas quoi le même goût que vous et là
malheureusement vous allez pas tous les
jours à Hong Kong ou je sais pas ou
ailleurs et donc
mais ce que je crois parce que pour en
revenir à l'amitié puisque c'est c'est
le thème
je pense que dans l'amitié et là je vous
rejoins il faut 10 on distingue la
techno comprend ça j'en suis sûr c'est à
dire on distingue et ça a été dit par
notre ami sociologue qui est c'est un
coin particulier et puis c'est quelque
chose qu'on retrouve périodiquement
parce que la question du réseau c'est
quand même la question de l'éphémère
donc ça
s'envole vous vous différencier vos amis
de de de peut-être de ce réseau de
connaissances que vous avez mais qui
peuvent être parfois très proches aussi
sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense qu'il y a une différence entre
les amis qu'on voit tous les jours qu'on
connaît depuis notre naissance et les
amis d'enfance nos meilleurs amis voilà
notre cercle proche et les gens qu'on a
pu rencontrer sur Internet qui sont
devenus des amis ou juste les
connaissances qu'on a et qui sont des
connexions sur Internet après moi je
suis pas tellement d'accord dans le sens
où je pense qu'on peut nouer des
relations très très intimes et très
fortes avec des gens qui sont à l'autre
bout du monde et qui peuvent devenir des
amis c'est comme ça enfin c'est l'heure
d'aujourd'hui c'est pas les mêmes
générations nous on fonctionne autrement
c'est pas le même rapport l'amitié a
évolué aussi nos rapports amicaux et il
y a un truc moi qui me qui me fait
tilter c'est quand justement vous dites
que maintenant le virtuel c'est le réel
moi c'est ce que j'explique tout le
temps maintenant il faut comprendre que
il y a plus de vie virtuelle et de vie
réelle le virtuel est devenu le réel et
c'est tout ça en même temps et c'est
important de le mettre en avant parce
que par exemple je vais prendre un sujet
précis et donc qui qui se distingue un
peu de du sujet initial sur l'amitié
mais par exemple le cyberharcèlement il
y a cyber violence c'est que tu es
sexuel aussi violent ça c'est pas la vie
réelle c'est pas la vie virtuelle c'est
la vie réelle maintenant la vie
virtuelle a un impact sur la vie réelle
que ce soit les mauvais côtés que les
bons côtés parfois on va finir par lier
des d'amitié très très forte et qui sont
nécessaires par exemple vous disiez par
rapport au lobby par rapport à tout ça
quand on a 15 16 ans même 13 14 ans et
que je prends un sujet moi qui me qui me
tient à cœur et qu'on et qu'on découvre
voilà que finalement on rentre pas dans
les normes de la société par exemple et
qu'on est homosexuel comment on fait
quand on a personne autour de nous et
qu'on sait pas qui se fait et ben on va
sur internet et il y a des gros pays il
y a ça et on trouve des gens qui nous
ressemblent et là on peut créer des
amitiés qui sont mais incroyables à
l'autre bout du monde à l'autre bout de
la France et qui sont plus importantes
que les amitiés qu'on a droit dans le
réel parce que dans le réel c'est plus
compliqué de nouer des relations
dans un vrai soutien pour pour vous les
les ça a été un soutien sur sur d'autres
sujets mais c'est vrai que moi quand je
me suis questionné sur mon orientation
sexuelle et que j'étais perdue vraiment
et que j'ai besoin de soutien j'ai
trouvé des gens qui avaient les mêmes
problématiques etc et là ça fait du bien
et pourtant c'est si virtuel et parce
que virtuel c'est aussi le réel
maintenant j'ai mis le mot de la fin
pour vous et sur votre usage des réseaux
sociaux avec les
en fait moi après faire des amis les
gens avec qui je parle le plus sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est des gens que je
vois le plus dans la vraie vie donc du
coup en fait je suis assez d'accord avec
vraiment les deux je suis assez d'accord
avec Anita sur le fait où je vois pas en
fait pourquoi
bah ça changerait quelque chose dans le
sens où il y a plein de gens qui ont
beaucoup plus de mal à aborder les
autres dans la vraie vie et que bah les
réseaux sociaux facilitent beaucoup ça
et pour trouver directement des gens
avec qui on a les les
choses en commun et en plus bah du coup
pour les aborder mais c'est vrai que moi
personnellement c'est pas enfin c'est
pas forcément mon cas genre les les gens
que je vois le plus bah c'est les gens
avec qui je parle le plus sur les
réseaux sociaux pour vous le virtuel
c'est le réel aussi bien merci merci
beaucoup à tous les quatre d'avoir
échangé sur ce beau sujet de l'amitié et
l'amitié dans notre monde d'aujourd'hui
et je termine avec une très brièvement
une petite bibliographie sur l'amitié
parfaitement subjective alors je voulais
citer l'éthique à nicomac ou Aristote
définit les types d'amitié on a commencé
quand même pas la base par cela je
voulais parler de amitié les Essais de
Montaigne les relations avec la Boétie
plus contemporain l'ami prodigieuse
Elena Ferrante et toute la tétralogie
mon livre préféré voilà sur
l'adolescence et sur l'amitié l'ami
retrouvé de Fred Ullman et puis je cite
également bien les livres de Colombes
Schneck deux petites bourgeoises qui
parlent en 2021 mensonge au Paradis qui
vient de paraître chez Grasset et bien
sûr Philippe diverger et je cite votre
livre votre livre en plein dans notre
sujet l'amitié à l'adolescence à la
découverte de soi parue en 2022 merci à
tous très bonne suite des programmes sur
Public Sénat bye bye
[Musique]